um so the government's announcing plans
to allow
uh people who come into contact with
someone who's tested positive for covert
19
to take a daily test rather than
self-isolate is that something that
labour backs
i think we're certainly very keen to see
it made easier for people to go about
their normal lives particularly because
we've long had concerns
about how the economic impact of of
quarantine
arrangements on people because the
government hasn't been quick to come
forward with financial support
so i think i think it's very welcome
that that we're exploring
ways in which we can make it easier for
people to get back to normal
more quickly but obviously as always
with this we want to follow the science
we want to make sure that it's robust
we meet regularly with the sage
scientists and it's something that we'll
certainly be asking them
questions about next time we meet the
issue is i guess the
reliability of these lateral flow tests
is there a concern that they're just not
good enough at picking up
asymptomatic cases well
there have been concerns raised by some
scientists the
there's a growing body of evidence um
around them
and that's one of the things that we one
of the reasons why we meet regularly
with the sage scientists is because
we want to make sure that they are
robust that we're not
taking measures to unlock that people
desperately want to see that people
desperately need
that will unravel the amazing progress
that has been made through the national
vaccination effort over the last few
months there's light at the end of the
tunnel i think we can all feel it we can
see it
but we're not there yet and so we've
just got to take these things carefully
it's right to do tests it's right to do
trials before
we pilot them i think largely speaking
we are with the government on this we
want
to unlock we want to get back to
whatever normal looks like on the other
side of this
but what we don't want to do is to
unravel the progress that we've made in
the last few months
uh talking about the success of the
vaccine rollout sunday times reporting
today that the fisa
vaccine could be rolled out to secondary
school pupils from september is that
something that labour would support
the the the view that's been given to us
by
uh the scientists that we meet with
chris whitty patrick valance
and others is that there is some
evidence around
transmission rates amongst secondary
school students so it may be
beneficial obviously this is a
fast-moving
scenario the evidence is massing all the
time
but it certainly would make sense to us
if if the scientists believe that this
is beneficial it would make sense
to us to offer it to secondary school
pupils over the course of this pandemic
we've seen
some measures taken particularly in
secondary schools to try to keep
people safe and to keep teachers safe
and teaching staff
as well and i think the approach that
has been taken by most schools is one
that we very much support which is about
supporting
parents and young people to be able to
make good decisions rather than
you know tough enforcement measures
making people comply with regulations
we've been told all the way along by
public health officials that doesn't
work in terms of public health you have
to
work with people in order to to advance
public health not
um you know it's the it's the carrot not
the stick
okay i'm keen to move on to talk about
the
recent row over the renovations of boris
johnson's flat we were speaking about it
with dominic raab who said the prime
minister has been crystal clear there's
reviews going on
uh now it'd be wrong for them to comment
any further
now the electoral commission is
investigating whether offenses have
occurred
over the funding of that redecoration
if it finds that offences have occurred
should the prime minister resign
well i think that the we don't need an
electoral commission
inquiry to know that the prime minister
is withholding information
from the public that rightly belongs in
the public domain
it's appalling that we're in a situation
where he won't come clean
about who loaned him money or gave him
money
and what favors or promises may have
been given
in return we already know that this is a
prime minister who frankly thinks that
the rules don't apply to him
and his friends he's quite happy for his
cabinet ministers to break the
ministerial code
and then not resign he's quite happy for
his adviser to drive around the country
with covid in the middle of lockdown and
not resign
and i think people are angry actually
that in a year when we've all followed
the rules
often at great personal cost not saying
goodbye to loved ones in care homes not
attending funerals
of people who've died we've followed the
rules because we know that the rules
matter
and yet over and over again we've seen a
prime minister who thinks that the rules
frankly don't
apply to him it's appalling is it really
fair to talk about
people not being able to attend funerals
because of covert and somehow equate
that to
boris johnson and how he funds the
redecoration the flat particularly when
he says that he did actually end up
paying
for it it is absolutely fair because he
is a pattern of behavior from this prime
minister that we don't need inquiries
to evidence he evidences it himself
every single day when he refuses to tell
the truth when he refuses to come
clean there is an arrogance at the heart
of this that's
that that he seems to believe that we
don't deserve to know the truth
about what goes on in government this
really matters because
at the moment we don't know who the
prime minister is beholden to
we don't know if he's promised them
anything in return we don't know what
the implications of that
are and over the last few weeks we've
seen this raft of
revelations about the financial networks
at the heart of government
cabinet ministers who profited from the
pandemic favors that have been done
for for donors from the tory party
we've seen foreign dictators who are
able to pick up the phone to the prime
minister
and give instructions and instead of
pushing back on those instructions
he puts one of his top advisors onto the
case
if if the prime minister is beholden to
other people
who is he not serving and that's the
people of this country and that's why
this really matters this is about
integrity
it's about trust and it's about whether
there's one rule for them and one rule
for everybody else and i feel that
particularly
strongly at the moment with the year
that we've had i think
other people in this country feel
particularly strongly about it as well
it's just simply not good enough
we'll find out how people do feel on
thursday of course so in the
local elections and just one more
question on the um
allegations around the prime minister
there are reports in the sunday times
at least one conservative donor was
approached
about paying the bill for the prime
minister's child's care now number 10
said that the prime minister paid the
cost
they don't seem to have confirmed
whether he paid the original bill
dominic raab
earlier said that this was just gossip
what do you make of it
i just think you know if the back of 11
years of huge
cuts to public services and to austerity
when
ordinary families in this country have
seen their income squeezed and have
struggled
to pay their child care costs themselves
it is extraordinary that we've got a
prime minister who is going around
saying he can't possibly afford to pay
his hope for his own child care costs
at a time when he earns he's in the top
one percent of earners
in this country and over and over again
that's the pattern that we've seen one
rule for them
one rule for everybody else whether it's
um saying that he can't afford to pay
to have his flat redecorated at a time
when they're denying leaseholders
the the financial help that they need in
order to make their flats safe
after the grenfell tragedy it's just one
rule for them one rule for everybody
else that's what's so distasteful about
all of this
um important of course to say of course
that number 10 is saying that the prime
minister's pay the cost of the child
care
and the flat renovation no one's and
profited from any of the
contracts as well now despite all the
noise that labour
has made about this the fact that you
say that people
are really bothered that it seems to be
in your view one rule for
boris johnson one rule for anyone else
labour is still
behind in the polls i accept that things
seem to have narrowed slightly
in the last of 24 hours but you haven't
been in the lead in a major poll
since january given the local elections
are just a few days away are you a bit
worried
i'm not worried but i'm not complacent
i've never
taken votes for granted when i was first
elected in wigan
lots of people said to me well this is a
labor seat i don't believe in labour
seats or tour receipts
people in in the across this country
make up their own minds in elections and
we've seen that with big seismic shifts
over recent years we're going out we're
fighting for every vote we're not taking
a single one for granted
to be honest with you sophie i have felt
in the last few weeks that something is
shifting
a little it doesn't feel like 2019
which was the worst election i can ever
remember fighting
in my lifetime i think people have
understood that labour is under new
management
and they're looking at us again i think
they are really concerned about the way
that this prime minister
carries on and the way in which it seems
to be one rule for them and one rule for
everybody else so i think people are
starting to think
again about labor whether that
translates into
to good results at these local elections
i'm not sure to be honest we've got a
big mountain to climb
and uh with it's going to take time to
rebuild that trust but we're going out
we're fighting for every single vote
and whether or not we get a good set of
results in these local elections i think
they're likely to still be very
difficult for us and we're determined to
regain that trust this is personal for
me
you know lots of my constituents in
wigan have felt for a long time that
labour has been moving away from them
and i am absolutely determined that i'm
going to prove to them that that is not
the case that labour is coming home to
them
can't help but thinking listening to you
that it feels like a bit of a low bar
you're saying that it doesn't feel quite
as bad as 2019 which is the worst
election you can ever
remember from labor you know you're
talking about
we're in a situation where if labour
holds onto hartlepool a seat that you've
always held since it was created
in the face of the conservatives who've
been in power for 11 years and that
would be seen as
a success i mean how low is the bar well
i think the bar was
became pretty low in december 2019 when
we had our worst election results in 100
years and we saw our base collapse in
every nation region of the uk
but we're not unambitious for what comes
next and i think the torah
shouldn't take votes for granted we
people are looking at us again we are
starting to make progress you know got a
new leader in scotland
and asawa who's making a real really
good impact with the electorate people
can see
that he's absolutely determined to put
the future of scotland
right at the center of the debate in
scotland not just these divisive
questions that the snp wants to go back
to
so i i don't think that's a low bar i
think that's a level of ambition for
this country we won't be satisfied
until we've won people's trust we're in
power in towns and cities across the
country
and in westminster and we can start
actually delivering for people
again after a lost decade but that means
that we have to go out and fight for
every vote that's
you know don't read that from me as as a
lack of ambition
for this country it's just a recognition
that we've got a lot of work to do and
we're determined to do it
i'm keen to move on to your uh brief as
well uh dominic raj was talking about
the cuts to international aid talking
about
difficult decisions but they have to be
made in the face
of the economic crisis um you know we're
still spending 10 billion pounds on
international aid this year
is it right that we are scaling back
scandal spending
well the the problem is twofold one is
that with
scaling back uh spending that was
uh in the middle of a pandemic and that
is extraordinarily short-sighted it's
one of the greatest assets that the
united kingdom has around the world
we're highly respected in terms of of
age
and it gives us soft power and influence
around the world as well which is
something we need very much with the
you know rising tensions between china
and the us
the aggression from russia the situation
in iran and other
other things but it's also that what is
being caught
is just appalling i mean in the middle
of a pandemic to cut healthcare programs
to cut scientific research
just i just think it's it's unbelievably
short-sighted because in the end the
only way that the
the world comes through this is by
erasing
the virus everywhere in order to erase
it
anywhere and the uk has taken the acts
to programs that helps us to do that at
the very moment that they have been
most needed so it's a really
short-sighted decision it doesn't make
any sense and it absolutely undermines
our moral authority on a world
stage we're also seeing this appalling
situation in india
when it comes to clover 19 um really
troubling
to see some of these sort of stories
coming out there
are we doing enough to try and provide
assistance
i think we can and should do more um the
uk has sent
a small two i think two now small
shipments of
um of assistance to india but don't
forget it was india that stepped up for
us when we were
almost a year ago today in really dire
straits struggling to contain the impact
of the pandemic the prime minister had
just left hospital
we were woefully unprepared and we have
to appeal to the rest
of the world for help and india step
forward to prove the export
of huge amounts of paracetamol to the uk
because we're in danger
of running out so there are long and
deep ties between us and india that mean
that we should step up
and provide more equipment more support
we are world leaders
in genomic sequencing we can track and
map
how this virus is mutating and
developing
only a few months ago matt hancock said
we should make that capacity available
to the world
we should be offering that support to
india at the moment given that we've
seen new variants emerging
that are causing real problems for them
and it ultimately will cause real
problems for us unless we understand
what's happening
and stop them in their tracks okay yeah
really important
situation in india developing of course
and just finally while i've got you on
something
slightly different um caitlyn jenner
who's running to be the governor of
california and former olympic medalist
who's also a transgender
has said that trans athletes who are
born male
shouldn't be able to compete in girls
sports teams do you agree with that
i've always thought this is something
that sports governing bodies need to
determine
they need to work across the industry
and with stakeholders in order to
determine
the rules for their own sports there are
lots of grey areas
in sporting competitions that that need
to be clarified and need to be dealt
with and i don't think it's for
politicians
okay fair enough um thank you very much
uh lisa and andy there